I was thinking about the issue of
discrimination in relationship to sex
because I've been thinking a lot about
discrimination lately because everybody
thinks discrimination is a bad idea
which is a very stupid proposition
because you're discriminating all the
time and the most fundamental form of
discrimination is choice of sexual
partner and so you might say well why
should that even be allowed because it
is the most fundamental form of
discrimination so for example almost
everyone is racially prejudiced when it
comes to sexual partners so you think
well is that right is that a what about
are you to use age as an exclusionary
criteria probably to use physical
attractiveness only insofar as you're
able right you use it completely if you
could get away with it roughly speaking
but you can't because the most
attractive people aren't going to be
anywhere near you so you can't do it but
you'd like to health yes strength yes
wealth yes education
definitely so you it's unbelievably
discriminatory and so you might say well
why is that justifiable and it seems to
me that it's something like well you get
to say no to me if I get to say no to
you it's something like that we've
agreed that everybody gets to
discriminate on that basis and because
everybody can do it then it's fair it's
something like that it's very much worth
thinking about you know I don't know if
you know this but in Huxley's book brave
new world where the family had been
completely demolished right and children
were conceived in bottles and given and
produced in factories so the whole idea
of the relationship between sex and
procreation had become a taboo one of
the mantras the slogans of the society
was everyone belongs to everyone else
and so it was actually a social faux pas
to refuse to sleep with someone just as
it was a social faux pas to have any
exclusionary relationship because
another thing that you might notice is
that there's nothing more discriminatory
than falling in love with someone it's
like you're special and all the rest of
you muhahaha know so it's the ultimate
exclusionary act right and yet we
presume that that's
double not only acceptable we demand
that as a as a right and well that's
we're thinking about a lot